esto se pone cada vez más interesante
vamos a hacer ahora este ejercicio en el
que ocuparemos pedir prestado más veces
de las que hemos hecho vamos a ver en
nuestro análisis general 9.601 es más
grande que 8000 23 por lo que no tenemos
problema para hacer la resta pero
tenemos que uno es menor que tres por lo
tanto pediremos prestado y pondremos
aquí una estrellita cero es menor que
dos por lo que también pediremos
prestado y pondremos una estrellita
es más grande que el 0 vamos bien y el 9
es más grande que el 8 en la columna de
las unidades de millar
lo que haremos es una vez más separar
nuestros números en las categorías
correspondientes unidades de villar
centenas decenas y unidades
veamos 9.601 es igual a 9000
más 600 más 0 + 1 mientras que 8 mil 23
es igual a 8000
+ 0 centenas más 20 más 3
ok ya sabemos que vamos a pedir prestado
por lo que haremos lo siguiente vamos a
cambiar el color a los préstamos aquí
pediremos a la columna que sigue sin
embargo esta columna no tiene lo
suficiente para prestarnos en las
unidades así es que nos iremos a la
siguiente columna y aquí sin duda
tenemos bastante de donde pedir tenemos
600 unidades es muchísimo entonces
haremos lo siguiente este 600 lo
cambiaremos a 500
y le prestaran
bien a la siguiente columna que es esta
vamos a hacerlo el limpio para que sea
más fácil 9000 más 500 estos 500 que
hemos cambiado más 100 que son los que
nos ha prestado
el grupo de las centenas más uno
vamos bien y ahora digamos que al menos
ya puedo pedirle prestado este uno ya
puede pedirle prestado a este cien así
es que vamos a pedir prestado también
aquí y lo haremos con otro color
este cielo vamos a cambiar a 90
y nos prestará 10 para que los vemos a
este uno vamos a volver a poner el
limpio 9000
mars500
+ 90 que esté 100 se ha cambiado porque
nos ha prestado 90 pero los 10 que nos
falta se los sumamos al 1 y ahora
tenemos que de cualquier manera
500 más 90 más 11 es igual a 601 que era
este primer número
pongamos entonces el 8000
0 20 3 que vamos a restar
y veamos qué números nos da 11
3 es igual a 8
ya podemos hacer nuestra resta sin
problemas
90 menos 20 es igual a 70
500 -0 es igual a 500
y 9000 menos 8.000 es igual a mil por lo
que nuestro gran número es 1500 más 70 +
8 pues es igual a mil 578 vamos bien
ahora veamos este ejercicio aquí de una
vez
si este uno es más pequeño vamos a pedir
que nos presten uno porque nos vamos a
pedir que nos presten de la columna
anterior como no podemos pedir la de la
columna anterior nos vamos a la
siguiente y este 6 se convertirá en 5
mientras que éste se convertirá en 10
ahora ya puedo pedirle este 10 se
convertirá en 9
y este uno se convertirá en once
ahora podemos hacer realmente nuestra
resta
once menos tres es igual a ocho
nueve menos dos es igual a siete
5 - 0 es igual a 5 y 9 menos 8 es igual
a 1
tenemos exactamente el mismo resultado
que habíamos conseguido aquí abajo lo
importante de todo esto es que ustedes
vayan viendo como si no tenemos en una
columna previa nos podemos ir a la
siguiente pero hay que tener mucho
cuidado en siempre mantener el total
prestado para manejar los mismos números
9.601 lo podemos desmenuzar de distintas
maneras y con esto lograr hacer nuestra
resta nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo